alors rentre à la maison, je pense que
oui,
pour les
étrangers,
nous faisons un cercle autour de l'iceberg ouais,
très près,
ouais, garde un œil sur le Pays de Galles aussi,
notre ombre, n'est-ce pas, bonjour la
plus grande que nous ayons jamais
vue,
oh, là où est l'
ombre  ombre pouvons-nous voler un peu
plus loin et un peu plus bas, Le
et moi pour que je puisse la regarder pendant que nous
arrivons et j'espère que nous ne verrons pas l'
ombre, c'est pour la variation
et et peut-être encore 100 m plus
loin  plus loin si plus loin plus loin, plus
grande, plus grande distance, grand, plus grand
Cercle,
ok,
mec, ça arrive maintenant, ouais,
je descends bas, je reste là-haut, je ne le verrai peut-être pas,
l'ombre va vers le bas, non,
l'ombre est en bas. L'ombre de l'ombre est
descendue, ouais.
euh
ouais l'Ombre est
partie ok c'est bien merci peux-tu en faire
un pour
moi je vais tourner dans l'autre sens
ici arrêter l'enregistrement s'il te plaît non
non c'est un petit trou sous la glace a
ouais
ouais je fais un tour il y en a pas mal
je  je tire dessus 17h00
18h00
ok ici à droite oh ok beaucoup
de B ils sont sur l'eau partout
ici à droite ok juste peut-être juste
ralentir, faire un cercle autour d'eux pouvons-nous faire un
bon cercle
autour Cercle à droite  ici mais ici je peux
si tu veux ok ok il y en a un ici
ouais ce lot ici prochain
lot
tu l'as ouais j'ai ouais
sympa sympa ouais
ouais
bon l'un des meilleurs oiseaux photographiés jusqu'à présent
ouais ok arrête s'il te plaît
ok peut-être euh arrête un
instant s'il te plaît  arrête
d'enregistrer oh regarde ça ça va
être incroyable c'est
magnifique
hein ah regarde
ça bien
sympa
il pourrait y avoir de la bière polaire par ici
ouais ils aiment ils aiment la glace plus épaisse
je
pense que l'aceb à gauche est NI ouais
ouais viens autour de ça
six ok arrêtez l'enregistrement s'il vous plaît alors
qu'allons-nous faire il y a trop d'
oiseaux ok juste arrêtez
ici ne faites pas de verre B
[Musique]
oh comme ils attendent nous pouvons attendre quelques
minutes ici pour
vérifier peut-être aller juste un peu plus haut
pourrait être
e switch
wa
ça ok stop
Mec en fait il n'est pas tout à fait
deux, prends-le,
arrête d'
enregistrer, c'est
vrai,
tu cherches le
Lan, jetons un coup d'oeil un dernier coup d'
oeil tu penses que c'était de ce côté oui
ouais la dernière photo que j'ai prise était d'
ici je suis  euh
ok L'ombre est faible c'est bien c'est ok merci
d'avoir organisé ça pas de
problème je pense à
toi au moins on a une belle vidéo
tournée et quelques et quelques photos fixes et
quelques photos
fixes au moins tu ne t'es pas blessé
le plus
important allons-y  une autre
piste, peu le bleu, je veux
arrêter l'enregistrement
[Musique]
ok,
avant,
une
maintenant non, n'atterris pas, c'est stupide d'
atterrir non non non non non non, nous ne le sommes pas et
là, la dernière photo que j'ai faite était ce
look ouais  mais nous volions en
cercle et il aurait pu être projeté par le
genre de force centrifuge. J'aurais pu
faire un autre Lo encore 100 ans
plus
loin, volez de haut en bas, vous savez, comme
une recherche sur une grille, montez là-haut, faites demi-tour,
venez  retour ok arrête
d'enregistrer il
y a du CL derrière c'est plutôt sympa quoi
désolé F ok ouais ouais ouais
on peut faire le tour une fois de plus
y ouais c'est la
limite continue à venir autour d'un
Plus de GL complet
ok c'est une belle photo n'est-ce pas  oui super
photo ok ouais arrête d'enregistrer la
prochaine nuit que nous avons eu l'autre jour, c'était
mieux la journée parfaite
ok St pour les
supplications
ok
c'est une
gentille supplication
peut-être un peu de la main gauche ped si
nous voyons nous voyons une vue peut-être que maintenant je ne le fais
pas
tout à fait ok ok arrêter l'enregistrement
merci
pouvons-nous aller H [ __ ] gauche et
ralentir lentement sur ce prochain Little Rock
maximum [ __ ] gauche et ralentir un
peu
ok merci
voler normalement maintenant arrêter l'enregistrement